la situation à l'école et relève du
chaos on a eu le protocole là depuis
cette semaine qui était complètement
incompréhensible et efficace et là on
décide de l'alléger donc démarche
littéralement sur la tête
[Musique]
c'est une recommandation qui portent
essentiellement sur les soignants nous
allons discuter de cela on rendra
publique la vie vous verrez qu'on est
assez loin d'après le hcsp d'étendre le
ffp2 à d'autres catégories
professionnelles
[Musique]
il ya énormément d'établissements
scolaires en france où il y a
effectivement entre un tiers et la
moitié des élèves qui sont qui sont
absents quelle continuité pédagogique
dans ce cadre là quel sens ça de parler
de continuité pédagogique
dans ce cadre là
[Musique]